I've been listening to a lot of your live recordings and wondering if you
could explain a bit more. I have a lib note under my right arm that they biopsyed
and it showed cancer. By the end of the day, sometimes it is very sore and large
that goes down overnight. This last week it started on the left side. I understand
that they are our bodies car wash but at what point do they start to clear up or
swelling will down? Well your lib notes will increase in size if there's an
infection. If you have blockage in the lib note because you have some cancer
growing in the lib note, then it will increase in size at different times simply
because fluid goes through there. So remember your lib system is like an open-ended
capillary system. It isn't open-ended capillary system. I like it to have several
videos on the lib system on the number side. So do look at those but it's like your
storm sewers in your street. So if your street floods, you have ten inches of
rate overnight and water has to go somewhere and it's rinsing down to the
storm sewers. Well if you have blockage in that sewer in the in the street it's
going to back up and that's what could happen if you have tumor cells in the lib
note and then it's going to you're going to notice the swelling, you're going to
those swelling around that lib note, you're going to notice some lack of drainage.
But normally if there's a formal rain storm, they will back you know sewers can
back up because of that and that's where like if you have a horrible infection your
lib notes can get larger and then they will go back down. That's called a
lib note hypertrophy and then they do go back down. You probably notice this with
your children, if you have kids, they get it really sick or something and they have
swollen lib notes. Well that really swollen. There had hypertrophy to try to kill
an infection so and then they will go back down. So when lib notes themselves are
where the drainage tube of whatever area is being drained goes through and it's a
conglomeration of different white blood cells to be able to kill anything because
it drains back into the blood system. We certainly don't just want the
extracellular spaces, the spaces around your cells, the fluid to go into the
storm sewers. Then we're going to put it back in the blood stream, normal, your
storm sewers are going to that's like putting your storm sewers down in the
river, including the river. Well that wasn't a good idea when they decided to do
that a hundred years ago so they're changing those things. Well our storm
sewers are going right back into our river of our blood stream. But they have a
filtration system which kills any pathogens, called your lib notes. So that's
what your lib notes do. They filter this out so it kills any pathogens. So
that you're not actually causing a systemic infection.